foreign
put their lives online
every single day
we sleep good at night because these
guys deal with the ugly
[Music]
how are we gonna get out of here
Monday's for sure
you don't come out the same way you went
in
sea United States two suspects present
possession of God
so we need your connect we got a tip
from a confidential informant about a
stash we got suspicious you didn't
notify him on the warrant
just one of those things
watch yourself
remember that money house I told you all
about
I'm gonna need your help
you get a million bucks do you hear what
you're asking me to do
can't do this without you
I want to go through this it's an
informant
I don't think I could do this bro you
better do it
however can I explain this
you made me miss my Yankees game so what
do you got two males game basket
across the victim's door they know
exactly where the money is they don't
kill anyone
and you figure they were cops here
I've been having nightmares what if
somebody finds out
[Music]
Tommy taking money on the side
never
you got a dead cop a hero partner and a
widow this investigation is over my gut
is right on this summer all you got is
conjunction
[Music]
you're about an inch away from getting
bounced out of the IAB it's our jobs
debt the community uphold the law
sometimes you got to do a smaller wrong
for being right